complete my tweet from
2011 almost blank is just as scary as
blank both the blanks are the same oh
okay a swallowing a hot
dog B peeing in the bed C scratching
your nipples in public my inclination is
be peeing that is correct that's so
interesting what do you mean that you're
all that you're scared the anticipation
of it happening is almost as scary as it
happening I don't understand this I mean
maybe like like I used to have dreams
where I was peeing and like I would
always wake up and be like I almost
peed like I almost peed like like dreams
where I'm about to pee yeah yeah I know
that yeah so like it was I feel like
that was scarier to me than like that
almost peeing is is the same fear as
actually peeing in the bed now I'm now I
look back I'm like I was immature that
was wrong peeing in the bed is fun